[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
monday august 22nd i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
as you may know the crypto platform
ethereum is a ledger technology that
lets users build applications on top of
its blockchain
it's like an operating system for a
computer except instead of being run by
apple or microsoft it's decentralized
run by many computers that verify and
process transactions
now the non-profit that runs ethereum is
preparing for a major change to how it
operates
it's being called the ethereum merge and
it's got people in crypto land very
excited joining us to discuss what's
behind all this excitement and what the
change is in the first place is our
cryptocurrency reporter paul vina hey
paul thanks for coming back on the show
hi thanks for having me so paul start us
off with why ethereum is doing this
merge
so ethereum is doing this merge which is
basically a software upgrade and the
software upgrade is going to change the
way
the network operates and the design is
to make it less environmentally
hazardous to cut down on how much energy
it takes to run the network
networks like ethereum and bitcoin and
most of the all these other
cryptocurrencies really are open
networks anybody can download the
software log their computer on and and
act as an operator on the network
and what bitcoin and ethereum do right
now is they have these systems and
they're called proof of work but like i
said
running all that computing power is
extremely environmentally hazardous it
just uses up a lot of energy
so ethereum is putting in a system
called proof of stake
and rather than forcing people to use
computing power and thus energy you're
just you're putting up money you're just
you're staking a certain amount of money
to be a validator on the network and be
one of the operators they think it'll
you know might lower
ethereum's energy costs and usage by 99
which is great i mean it's a big deal
so they're making this switch kind of
from one method of doing things to
another and it should have these
environmental benefits but i'm wondering
if there are any other benefits that
ethereum might get out of doing this
change
hopefully what it will also do is it
will
speed up the processing of transactions
on the network which will reduce
bottlenecks there are a lot of
bottlenecks where sometimes transactions
all get there are just too many
transactions the network can handle and
you and it's like traffic on you know
route three in the morning going into
the city uh you just everybody can't get
through the lincoln tunnel at the same
time so hopefully it'll reduce
bottlenecks and that will lower the
costs to people actually on the network
uh there's a way that the you know you
pay a fee and the fee is supposed to be
small per transaction but when you get
these bottlenecks the fees are they sort
of recalibrate so that whoever pays more
can get their car through the tunnel
faster so the fees can jump up i mean
you know earlier this year jumped up to
200
per transaction which is just insane you
can't run a network on that
you know in in your recent newsletter
you mentioned that while this merge with
ethereum might be good for environmental
purposes it actually doesn't solve some
of the other problems that ethereum has
because of its goals can you explain
that a little bit i mean why won't it be
better
well what it won't do and what my mind
is still to this day ethereum's biggest
problem
is that it is just too difficult for the
average person to take the time to
educate themselves about ethereum
download the software
run it figure out how it's supposed to
be run
get a wallet learn how to secure it i
mean you know the stories of people who
have lost their money because they just
didn't understand the the security
requirements alone are legion like
there's no deposit insurance you know
you're not opening a savings account
where the bank is ultimately responsible
for it and if the bank fails the fdic
steps in and makes you whole you are
responsible for it there's just a lot of
steps to being on ethereum that most
people are just not going to take so in
the in the lead up to this merge what
has been going on with ethereum how have
investors and people who use it been
reacting
they've been reacting very very
positively you know the last
uh since late june when cryptocurrencies
all sort of bottomed out since late june
the price of ethereum
at one point it had doubled it was
trading under a thousand dollars in late
june and it got up to almost two
thousand dollars about a week ago and
most of that was just people getting
excited about this merge finally going
in because they've been talking about
this and building it for years and it's
gone through a series of delays and
there was never a firm date and they
never knew what it was really going to
happen or if it was going to happen and
i suppose you could still have a
situation where they have to delay it
again but they've kind of put in a
relatively firm date of about september
15th for this to go in so over the last
month or so people have been getting
excited that this is finally gonna
happen and traders have used that you
know as a spark for buying ether and
driving up the price and at one point
like i said it was up you know more than
100
i wonder if this kind of lead up to the
merger if this moment that ether is
having where it's saying we're going to
focus on kind of what we do and what our
purpose is
it represents any kind of shift in how
people are going to think about
cryptocurrency more broadly and what its
purpose is particularly given the the
lower values of some other tokens
i don't think so i think it's a good
question to raise but i don't think so i
mean the merge in and of itself
is not going to be the thing that
changes all of the cryptocurrency
markets fortunes you know all of the
really really big issues are still there
the regulatory uncertainty
the lack of security you know you really
in the crypto markets if you look around
there's almost a hack a week the
structure of the markets what we've seen
this year is that these things crash
hard and there are no backstops and
the lack of any sort of compelling use
case is still a big issue there still
isn't much that you can do with
cryptocurrencies besides trade them
and that's fine for a lot of people and
that's interesting for a lot of people
and people love making money so that
works but at some point you have to come
up with a very utilitarian reason for
people to be interested in this and to
want to use it
all right so still a lot of things to
consider in this market and for people
who want to keep up with all things
crypto they can sign up for your weekly
wsj crypto newsletter that's at wsj.com
all right that's our cryptocurrency
reporter paul vina paul thanks again for
joining us yep thanks for having me on
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you're a fan of our show
please leave us a five star rating and a
review wherever you get your podcasts
i'm zoe thomas for the wall street
journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]